well I think the Richards case is so
typical you know bad representation two
trials that were ridiculous no physical
evidence you know he's put there by a
snitch who actually did kill the person
and then the snitches has life and this
guy is being put to death on the 16th
when a mistake is made within a judicial
system people just do not want to admit
that mistake has been made so it becomes
impossible case after case after case to
to redress them and the only thing now
that is going to give him a chance to
survive is public opinion is
embarrassment is public embarrassment
both trials nobody saw the video of the
confession where the police are
practically spoon-feeding him what he
that should say and offering him to have
a lesser sentence that was never brought
up in the first trial so the first trial
was said to not be a good trial so they
gave him a second trial and then they
still didn't bring it off they still it
I mean that's how bad poor people his
representation is you know and that's
why rich people don't end up in these
situations because they have better
lawyers and so his I mean he's a perfect
example of what's wrong with the death
penalty and so of course I'm hoping that
some kind of exposure will give him the
opportunity to maybe you know get his
sentence at least commuted because he's
clearly innocent and on top of that the
guy who actually killed the person is
just in a minimum-security prison for
the rest of his life you know the
governor of Oklahoma is just a horrible
person and and a woman so it's even more
discouraging in terms of digging in and
not wanting to get
more information and because being tough
on crime means being for the death
penalty somehow that got established and
so when you're trying to protect your
political career it's so much more
difficult to have three sentences
instead of one you know and so you can't
ever look at the complexities of
anything if you want to keep your mantra
going and the fact that it doesn't work
nobody even talks about the fact that
the death penalty is not a deterrent
it's incredibly expensive the states
that kill the most people have the most
murder in those states you know it's
it's just the whole thing is a lose-lose
so just from the record of how many
people have been exonerated in Oklahoma
you would think that they would stop
doing it because they've been so many
people that have been proven to be
innocent they're over 20 in other
countries you know that was a good
enough reason to abolish the death
penalty but in America it doesn't seem
to be well this man is going to be dead
on September 16th if there's not some
kind of light shown on the particulars
of his career and to force the powers
that be to rethink it it's never because
of some kind of consciousness raising
that these things change it's always
because of some kind of embarrassment
and so this is where public opinion can
make a difference this is where having
letters sent the governor can make a
difference because then they understand
they've refused interviews they review
they're just trying to keep everybody in
the dark and so if you can get some kind
of public transparency for what's going
on that's about the only thing that will
save them